there's a British soccer lady whose name
is Alicia Leman I am told she's very
young she's 24 years old she is called
the sexiest soccer star in the world I
had never heard of her before this news
story but she gives me a little hope for
soccer which I have very low hope for
because women's soccer is not known for
its glamor it's known mostly for Megan
rapino and this lady is is very Nic
looking and just came out on a podcast
and said that she was offered more than
$100,000 to spend the night with a very
well-known celebrity she said the
message said I will pay Alicia 100,000
Swiss Franks to spend a night with her
but my answer was no way and just
100,000 and 100,000 Swiss Franks is
around
$110,000 it's almost one to one Swiss
Franks to
USD and she's a very nice looking lady I
know she is a nice looking
lady
but and I'm a married man and I try not
to think of other ladies but I was I
tried to think about this circumstance
this very very well-known actor or not
not actor just celebrity of some sort or
another who she has not yet named and I
thought would that really be fun would
that really even if she's a really
pretty lady would it really be fun to
pay this lady
$100,000 and then you know have some
moments of of physical pleasure and then
you're done with it and that's it would
would you feel good after that even if
she's super duper hot would you I I
don't think I would feel good after that
even if I had a billion dollars to burn
I think that would that would not be
great there's an old line in Hollywood
about prostitution and why Rich famous
successful people will go to prostitutes
and I the line is attributed to Carrie
Grant or no is it Carrie Grant or Clark
Gable or I don't know who knows some old
Hollywood guy and the line is you don't
pay the prostitute to come over you pay
the prostitute to go
home in other words yeah you're a big
movie star you could attract a woman
with a wink and a smile but that's the
point because then they all want
something from you uh whereas you know
if you pay a hooker in this case if you
turn a soccer star into a hooker then
they go home and they won't expect
anything from you but is that really is
that really fun or does that just make
you an
animal and you you get your physical
gratification and you you do whatever
weird thing kind of titillates you and
then I think at some point you remember
that the the woman is a person with a
soul and like reason you know and is
judging you even if you pay her $200,000
you say hey here's $100,000 for the sex
and here's another $100,000 not to judge
me please and don't and for me to still
be an upright person but it doesn't work
that way the very fact that you have
done that diminishes you and diminishes
her and diminishes
everybody and she made the right
decision here I'm glad she didn't take
the
money but this is not merely a matter of
personal choice or taste we know that
this stuff is bad and normal good
societies that flourish recognize that
it is the role of the political order
and community to discourage people from
doing weird stuff like this and to
encourage people to do good things that
will give them good lives if we can't do
that for whatever reason we're just
ideologically we've convinced ourselves
we can't make decisions we can't
discriminate between good and bad and
right and wrong we don't we just don't
know we don't know what our religion is
we don't know what we believe we don't
know what we we think is moral then we
have effectively ceased to be a country
already and we still got well maybe the
borders I don't know we've still got
maybe some of the institutions the kind
of we still but if you can't do that if
you can't tell who you are and what you
want and where you're going and what's
good and what's bad for all intents and
purposes you're no longer a country boy
what a great clip that was
now ring that Bell subscribe to the
Michael nlls YouTube channel we'll see
you next time